there's nothing like implied incest to
make any situation awkward and We're the
Millers drug dealer David Clark has to
smuggle an RV full of marijuana across
the border and needs a cover family to
help he enlists dancer Sarah Rose to be
his pretend wife and run away Casey and
his neighbor Kenny to round out the fake
family on the way they link up with
another family and Kenny starts crushing
on their daughter Melissa Kenny wants to
make a move but doesn't know how to kiss
so Casey and Sarah Rose give him a
detailed tutorial of course Melissa
walks in on them horrified not realizing
that these folks aren't actually family
at all awkward since this reveal
potentially threatens their cover story
more hijinks ensue for the Millers
according to actor Will Poulter the
scene was as awkward to film as it was
to watch